well, how are you there,
why are we, as long as the headquarters, let the pizza be
different, you don’t have a tablet rapes in
quarantine, the
temperature is, no, from Italy,
I came here under warranty,
I know 5 cities are closed with the army, you know
now the
army does not release directly 5 cantons, we are
not afraid and you will not die from  this and I’m
not crazy about this young
[music]
from here a man got off the flight from Milan
who turned out to be patient number
zero in Russia and we now know for sure
that the virus has entered Russia, the epidemic
may have begun and its consequences are
still difficult to predict
when the epidemic began in the ear  not the
Chinese government decided within a
week to build a new recreational
hospital for infectious diseases for people who
live with different species, but this is a new hospital
here in Moscow, which was given only to
those who are suspected of this new
virus, look this means 1 building
and here here in  this building where the
chambers on the eighth seventh floor
are these seven seven people
who have now been brought to quarantine
pr  I quite understand that on these ambulances
from 1 infectious disease they brought people here for
any soon, I can clean it now,
now I take the patients, I will sit here, I
go out, what do you do next, you go out
clearly not to be embodied on the site, the machine is being
processed completely, everything
is being processed, this is how
to cope  I can’t crawl somewhere
with my hand, there is a spray, if where I can
wipe it with a rag, well, it
happens before the product, this product
is applied according to the instructions, it should
be on the surface for 15 minutes, then it
is washed off, plus we have views
for a
special lamp that works  all
the time we were
in the car all the time while we were in my car
and then 20 minutes after the
car was already empty, this is
enough for our volume of the car’s cubic capacity to be
fully processed gives a
100% result for a viral
infection and people get here here
I don’t understand about  the gateway means here all the
people in the receiver are also completely
absolutely as it means in Chinese films
about space, we believe that every person
who gets here is potentially
dangerous,
we still don’t know this, the whole event is
held in costume, yes, we have an electric train x.
come on
[music]
and this was read by a respirator not a mask, this is a
normal human
human to understand.
offend the
hatch hatch for nonsense.  company virus infection to
species 19 occurs by airborne droplets
when sneezing and coughing,
even just during a conversation, if you
stand close enough, viral
particles can travel through the air
at a distance of up to one meter and then
settle on surfaces, so you
can also get infected if you touched
such a surface and then touched the
mouth of the nose or eyes through the upper
respiratory tract, the virus enters the
body, a cough appears and a high
temperature
then it can descend into the lower
respiratory tract and cause
progressive respiratory failure not in mania
such a severe course of the
disease and also fatal cases most
often  occur in people over 60 years of age
still at risk people with
cardiovascular diseases
diabetes chronic respiratory
diseases such as emphysema
cancer patients in general the younger and
healthier you are the less likely you are to
get sick and get a serious
complication if infected with a virus and  it has
selectivity,
it has selectivity, but a lot of
vector let's look under the
data that we have and let's not
fantasize, we know that
there are almost no cases among young children,
not only deaths, I emphasize
there are no cases, that is, something in small
children is not something that does not give the virus on  to
join them with age, the number of cases
increases and after 20 already to leave
quite rapidly, but there is no death 1
death actually appears from 50 and above,
and they die from all carry and above up to but the
person who discovered the virus this
coronavirus is this Chinese doctors he
was 33 years old
why  he died well, first of all, she didn’t
open antokha noticed that there is a
very strange group fellow, the
person was smart
you don’t forget this is the dose of any sorry
even a child if you put them in a box with
these mice
sorry there will be remember the virus
gives a million options there and who
will be found  some that will catch on in
real life this does not happen we do not
have such contact with that
when we have a huge,
most terrible, highest percentage of illnesses
and deaths among health workers,
therefore, we will consider that a group of
health workers belongs to a separate
risk group, why do you represent a
ventilator,
otherwise the machines breathe during the days of the night and the
nurse runs every minute
checks  it doesn’t flow, it doesn’t work, how it
works, and these machines drive these
endless
millions of these viral particles, of course,
sooner or later, God forbid, but if
her mask got wet there or something else, you
understand, yes, that is, we will assume that
there is a population and there are health workers
these are two big differences, pay
attention to how it started and the translation is
now an outbreak in italy the patient was admitted
coughing and sneezing he felt bad
he was not non-lethal not fatal
feeling everything is bad and for a week they treated him
my Italian friends and did not even ask
that he came from China  and in a week
how many people he has there in his hospital
zara  zil that's what we have now in italy
such a fee for us to settle
as passionate guests with a
beautiful view of the moscow ring road
kristina and I can do the camera like
this and sit now in a mask
why are you in boxing but we still have
it because we still have a mask
mode you returned to Russia because of the
big yes I went to competitions in
Italy when there was no
epidemic yet, no outbreaks of course I do
n’t know anything I
went there on Friday February 21 I
returned on Monday 24 I went there
already with a
slight cough, so in principle I
was sure that  I couldn’t pick up anything from there,
but after a
few days after returning home, I
felt a little worse
as my sister, who simply didn’t have
contact, but she wasn’t with me,
Italy, so we decided to just
play it safe, because then my
lethal both went to another country
to play it safe to take a test to do this, they
removed that it only takes
three to four hours, so I arrived before the test for
coronavirus, they said that it takes  it takes
three or four hours, that is, you need to come
soon, she will take you away for
analysis, she takes you somewhere to drink and
analyze
you while the titans of home conclusion, but
as soon as it becomes clear that you are
great lordly people, if you,
well, the first test turns out to be positive,
then naturally the gas will stabilize you like this
we had the beginning of information in all the media
and on the Internet you build gave me a very
call an ambulance yes yes we called an ambulance
because it was written that it
was better not to go anywhere in case of any suspicions
immediately call soon we identified soon they
looked at me they put me an angel of
revenge
hotels orvi and  they said that you only do the test
in the first infectious diseases hospital and
we have to go there, that is, they
took us there.
sterile that
it's like a quarantine, I imagined
that everyone would be separately, I had to say  to
isolate the axis from each other upon
admission there, I was settled in a
universal ward, but I was there alone
the next day and throughout the
next day they began to settle in with us
and calves, and
for the end of Saturday we already had a
full ward by the middle of even
Saturday afternoon  we had a full ward,
but they were all people with suspicions of
coronavirus, these are all people who just
returned to this,
not water, that is, all people had some kind of
ailments, yes, that is, people with
suspicions, and not just that you
suddenly lost some  Moscow people with a
sore throat yes no no no, that is, they
were all people, but after listening to their stories, it is clear
that most of them went
again to Italy, already sick, returned
just like me and fear and, so to speak, be a
responsible citizen, they decided to just get
checked out, no one knew  what kind of
detail is there for a certain amount of time,
so in the end we started talking in
different people in other wards 11 wards
were on our floor in each ward
lived six  man here I had a soul day a
separate toilet for everyone, that is, for everyone,
yes now you are where you are
now we are in the hospital new
municipal hospitals in the
kommunarka glade do not open the basin yet, that is, it
was not an open hospital which is now
completely redesigned here
one by one  before they transported such an infection
right there to a communal apartment and all of us after we started
writing and calling who you can who you can’t
at all we called Rospotrebnadzor
medals at the Ministry of Health Rospotrebnadzor
listened to you and just hung up
at first we tried to just go to
our doctor, that is, to understand in general  what’s
going on why are we lying here, not treating anyone,
just locked up, in fact, everything she
went to the hospital
very on time when people began
to suspect the cow virus, in
general, we didn’t have a doctor, we started calling and
naturally we couldn’t get through to the head doctor’s doctor
further at the Toshiba metro station Rospotrebnadzor
anywhere  as a result,
there was no help for two days  We are calling
the Rospotrebnadzor’s unified information center,
you called the Rospotrebnadzor’s unified consultation
center,
we draw your attention to the
fact that in the service quality control body,
stay on the line, the first
freed operator
will answer you in
Inglis, the prize of the post, people are not able
to hire a normal half a cent, of course, this
prohibits
[applause]
here  I have a temperature of 40 I came from
Tehran and I want to know what to do and
now I’ve been calling the Rospotrebnadzor for a minute and a
half, hello, we understand that
no Rospotrebnadzor service exists
further, we call the press secretary directly,
call the Rospotrebnadzor because
we have nothing to do Rospotrebnadzor press secretary
a  all their
phones are turned off
there, that is, this organization that does not
exist amazing people have
read such a woman I saw
twice at some press conferences
who heads this service and not a
single phone answers amazing
this Elena press secretary of
Rospotrebnadzor I wish everyone  for ladies and the
mobile phone is also real like
in any other, it is not available,
so we call further where we
call further to the infectious diseases hospital, we
call who actually get people
with the corona virus, there are already two of them in
Russia,
hello, you called the
fanfiction clinical hospital number  one
dial the extension number or wait
for the operator's answer
I love archived conversations I record the
reference 1 of the infectious diseases hospital for
reference we call you will not understand no one
picks up the phone infectious diseases hospital
give
how good it is that you took the third number
in the city of Moscow where I am trying to
call you know I have recently returned
from Berlin  and I have a temperature of 38 and I
have a suspicion that a coronavirus
infection where I can take a test
so well, that is, if I come to you
at the hospital, you will take
test strips from me, I have an outbreak, but it’s not
possible only if you’re not late,
but it’s the same  not a quick test this is i want a
thread and how many did you put in this
way  Well, thank you very much,
because it worries you once there and
wants to find out from you, and I, that is, it’s
impossible, it’s impossible, just for
communication, I’ll tell you that you
didn’t say that anymore that he brought a leaf to
Stockholm by rank, I’ll tell you, they’ll
come home to me immediately  and they’ll take it and
call it soon, I understand, I understand everything,
follow
it, so it means it’s impossible, she says,
but nevertheless, from Moscow time she answered me, which
means the press secretary of Rospotrebnadzor
Elena, good afternoon.
This is Anton Krasovsky
.  in fact, we called you and his
reference service of Rospotrebnadzor.
all this was under cameras and we were trying to
figure out how to take a test
for the corona virus.
found out that none.  goodbye
everything is fine yes thank
you minister who are the ministers of
health who came to us
after all this hype what about you and about and
animals it was everyone walking through the logs of a
jumper yes for the minister it is in a white
sweater to the deputy minister
yes yes city and for dirty to the
federal  to my town with a short
beard,
I am myself, that is, he came to us
after all this, otherwise we have to convince us
that we specially built a
hospital for you and only for you we opened it yesterday, it
turns out that it was still possible to
solve peacefully, you understand why this hype
was  you just need someone
to call us, his understanding, as it were, but
that’s okay, as I understand it, pants are observed
more than not a couple, because in that
hospital
here she was a girl in the ward she
looks like a mushroom b and not and the card
says that they give her  some kind of
drugs and in the end it didn’t
give anything, that is, we just put it there,
we were fed,
wait, I can just take you for
coronavirus 1  you took the result,
we are looking for a negative result for you, a negative
result yes yes, and nevertheless you must
serve two weeks of quarantine correctly
and understand
yes, because as we were told that
Rospotrebnadzor issued a new decree
stating that the incubation period of this
virus is two weeks,
can it  show yourself on any of these
days, therefore, over the course of all
fourteen days, 33 tests will be sorted out for
1 3 the tenth day
to swim, well, that is, you do not regret
that you turned to the doctors and ended up
in quarantine, that is, you
treat accordingly,
you know, I a thousand times  to be
honest, I regretted it when I was there because it
was scary, just like they gave everyone
healthy 1 maza,
yes, that is, we could not just lie there, as it
were, with the girl getting
pneumonia, that is, there are just
people with a full range of different diseases,
I don’t say  that maybe even with a
coronavirus but got sick with something
else, no matter how I don’t think that you get sick with a
sore throat, as it were, they will trim  the
version of the crown to me is like the base blooms warmly, that
is, it was just right for the red that
for your life, of course, just for your
health and it was just scary
because no one reacts to anything
at all, so it was scary because it
and  you seem to call organizations that
deal with
people who are sick and but no one cares
about it, you seem to know that on the
side, in fact, it all works like that, but
until you yourself find yourself in this situation
and you yourself don’t understand in your own skin what it’s like, of
course, well, you never  you won’t believe
that this is real, this is how it happens in
Moscow, I entered the first infectious diseases hospital, that
is, this is the fruit of the poet’s defense why do we
even have infectious diseases hospitals
anywhere in the world there are no infectious diseases hospitals
because if you behave normally
in hospitals,
then people are inside yes you sleep alley
have the opportunity to isolate well
we do not believe in ours whether we have made
separate isolates get yourself a local
ward with a patient who is excreting the virus,
well, about  than I say that our
system, that is, the belief in what kind of bastard he
also adapted to punctures, would our
healthcare system not have a rogue at ease
200 meters won Olkhovka a
new metro station in the field as in China
directly steel as in China directly meters the
field was built and  a hospital of 160 thousand
square meters
if I get sick in the city of Moscow, I
will definitely make sure that they brought me here if a
person becomes ill if
breathing difficulty
should be taken to the hospital and yes, you need to dial
0 3 fractions of 103, a trained team will arrive
with their algorithms, scripts and
procedures, assess the situation in detail
will collect and python from because it can, of
course, be based on a living patient and did not
go to italy from him again anton
who yesterday visited his grandmother
absolutely came from this and the
tone is not only the patient himself but
this is his environment with whom he contacted
if we understand according to the protocol  something is a
patient with an acute respiratory viral
infection who, in addition, has
contact with a risk group, then this  about the percentage
for hospitalization one of the hospitals in
Moscow there is working on this program in the
presence of an elderly patient has a temperature
above 37 5 and catarrhal phenomena cold
sore throat cough and snot is
an absolute indication for observation in the
hospital and quarantine for some reason
if you have  or not, even if there
is no body of objective circumstances, conditionally
contacts with Chinese alliances, or we already
understand that it is in the general population of our
metropolis that are the gates of
how many of us are 5 airports to highlight
clearly to say that you are not out of
VKontakte after you have taken three
times the analysis  therefore, I think, given the
high risks for elderly patients, it is
probably right to
seek professional medical help
if there is a season for such a situation, I
think that for this category of our
patients, home quarantine and better
history is given with you, ideally waiting for 14
days, we begin to describe when
negative analysis new will
arrive
d  I think that of course your forecasts will be, but the
hour we see today the
Chinese chart has fallen sharply there are three
options for predicting the Chinese chart
it has fallen sharply why because you
have increased in the population you acquired
immunity most likely and
I don’t see another explanation for another explanation because
mass vaccination is not  it was therefore
probably possible that three scenarios are possible, the third
scenario is the worst when, despite
everything for the punitive measures that are
being implemented and it seems to me that Moscow has
something to show, for example,
to our beloved Italians who relaxed their legs for the
weekend for just one
weekend and shipped ups and that’s all and service
things 5 5 cities are already closed with the police arch
nd when is the first story the second story
is a month of hesitation and verse it but i
s still seasonal yes yes no and the third optio
is the usual seasonality of the new coron
virus where it came from the most
mportant thing is that the source of this bat about
the last  deca
more and more cases of confirmation  who claim that
bats are the source of a boring
infection is a very important word, that is,
when an epidemic happens among mice,
they get so much virus that these
viruses are a huge
range of different variants of actually
the same virus and here for
this huge range of variants
there is a
virus that can make the so
-called periscope from one species of
vertebrates to another in this is called
cross will write off the transition this is a very dangerous
thing because a
pathogen like ebola or like sars is not
adapted to us ebola and sars is also a
bat all bats can
cut and club  they become fees the
only parasites we inherited from
bats from the time when we
lived in caves,
and that is, they are not new to us in terms
of the human species, but in recent
years something has changed in the
environment, a
huge increase in population, we have
never been in  such close contact in both
Africa and China,
bats began to represent
certain such with tamed treatment
they have become fashionable to collect as
possible ways to cure various
chronic diseases that is when
you have such an interest more
and more people hunt them
further and further they climb and
more and more encounter different
viruses so we  we have corona viruses
an attempt to transition almost every five
years, that is, the Chinese not only eat mice,
but make all sorts of poultices and medicines from them,
or something new, yes, of
course they rub the bones, they sell separately the
ears of this
in order to begin to
understand
this, when I understood it only when I
was just in my ear, I didn’t go to this very
market, it was well, the 2000s and
I saw bear paws running separately, and
why paws the
rest of gretel does not matter, the
main thing is these paws in them there  everything
in the world and everything, so to speak, is treated by
bear paws so well it
means  this virus appeared, it brought it from
bats to a person what happened
next what happened next 1 virus
got into 1 person in this Ural
bazaar
and the person was sick quite hard
unfortunately it is impossible now to establish
whether he died or he recovered the next one
died, that is, the transition from the
murine  a virus from one person to
another, a mouse virus mutated or is it
still the same virus
here occurs in variation, let's say
that the same gene remains and
one or two replacements occur in it, I think it's
wrong to call mutations because
these variations go on all the time, this is Ethan, this is a
mistake and  reading or a natural
mechanism for the so-called
diversity, so it was shown that
Khan's
already had this data came from one
mouse from one virus, that is, among these
billions of viruses that were in mice,
there was still one that could
do something to cling to our recipe
getting inside  cells the
virus is in a difficult situation
enzymes are not the same  the birds are not the same all in
another place everything the devil knows how to
do and he needs to multiply he very
much depends on this, so to speak,
whether his offspring will shield him
begins to crowbar in this cell
somehow some particles he builds there the
devil  he knows how the cell immediately
scatters into heaps and a sick hybrid, and the
virus is transferred to the hotel and 8 is an important point,
but he has already moved from contact number 1 from 1
contact number two, he is a little
more adapted here, you immediately need to
add one thing in total, at
least 40 crowns are known  viruses in people, or
at least 20 are already known that
cause yes, we don’t know anything,
because if you sneezed and there
we ford who pay attention to it,
so when we reach this
state with a new virus, then
everything will be all right  but in order to
reach it it is very long with the song
coronavirus, it is because the corona virus is
that it has a crown, these are such spikes, prominent
processes in which the sp  special
protein with protein thanks to which the virus
enters the cell they work like
master keys
cling to the corresponding receptors
on the surface of the cell they
deceive the cell then it takes the virus for
its own and is ready the virus RNA is injected
into the cell and immediately the infected cell
turns into a factory for the production of the
virus then new ready-made virus and
leave the host cell to
infiltrate the next cell, and so
on, this is the relationship again of the
serious condition of the sick, their serious
state of health, this virus is very
interesting, these crowns, they make a
fake, that is, we have not come up with anything new in the world,
they tell the cells what they
carry  something very useful for cells and
cell-drops with pleasure, apparently to
cells of old organisms, this is
useful that something of itself so at least
pretends to be much more needed
and therefore they cling immediately to as
soon as they can, you imagine
, I walk nasty  I say I have not seen such cunning parasites for a long time,
we started  from the fact that it
appeared in the ear not from the Ukrainian market,
it spread to the entire province,
what will happen next, now we see that the
number of new cases in China is
declining correctly to 20,000 people
have already been discharged from recreational hospitals
into the ear, not only into the ear, but the whole epidemic has
spread  we see the world, we see
Italy, we see the amazing Iranian
cases in which we also don’t really
understand how they came from why there are so
many of them, for example, what are the
predictions, in principle, how many
people in the world should get sick, then
anton, you are absolutely right, how can we
model an epidemic based on hijack the
answer is as always
ambiguous yes and no let's look
like this first high virus which
generation is the earliest the most evil the
most unadapted the worst he
was he the virus does not want to kill us he
wants us jeeves and to adapt to us
multiply you are good to me good  this
type of symbiosis and we will live together, but
unfortunately at the first stage  he ca
n't do that here we have a ukrainian
outbreak you look outside the ear it's
not already in general the level of common
flu can be even a respiratory
infection lower than flu this is one of the
main streets in the ear not connecting parts
on both sides of the river on ordinary days here  7
point character traffic jam now there are
several cars never filled with people the
area is
now as empty as possible
only a few cars what you do in the ear
not specifically in china i work in the ear
will not help as if by chance
a half a month ago or three
months ago, how did you find out, specifically,
it started a month and a half ago, that is, there
was a specific moment when it became
clear that the situation was serious, that is, it
happened there literally in a day or two
, that is,
if my memory serves me, it was
like  the twenty-second number of December 22,
we calmly walked, so the next day
I decided to go
well, to go to the city center and a friend
told me that it wouldn’t work because
the metro was closed, I didn’t believe it, well,
because for a city of 14 million people, the
closed metro is a very serious measure.
here you can see the same thing is closed,
that is, like this, then on the 22nd you realized
that the metro was closed what happened next,
well, for the first two or three days, of course, panic
because we all have Internet
news instantly scattered all over the
Internet, parents, relatives, friends began to call us
to be interested in how you are
doing what exactly the Chinese then
said what to do oblige
to wear a mask, that is,
not to go out at all unnecessarily, but here
again, several stages can be distinguished,
that is, as soon as the corona as soon as the
corona virus appeared there for the
first three four five days everything  were
frightened of everything, sat at home, then
quietly, quietly, the panic subsided, everyone
began to  to leave because the
grocery stores were open by that time
;  free access wanted to go
out, this railing came out to the fact that, well, again, the
number of infected began to increase,
apparently the authorities, having seen this, decided to take even
stricter measures and ban
it, such forays into the store are obtained,
that is, now a large store
just can’t get in, you need to have
permission there is one person  from the
company from the entrance of the yard to has the
right to go to the store and buy there
for the whole yard, relatively speaking, and leave with these
huge packages and distribute them, but
here is a large vegetable
market where we usually bought food,
products, vegetables, fruits, is closed not to
get into such  Here are ready-made sets,
that is, each package is the same. I
have fruits and vegetables. The most
necessary things. Another example of how food is
distributed into ready-made sets
and then signs with such papers
who owns what. Local
residents come and take away.
Here is another grocery store.
One of the largest supermarkets.  in
the two-story area, I won’t get here, that’s for
sure  but don’t even try, otherwise they’ll take away
ok ok the axes
lock the food in such packages that you already know
on them there are tags according to the standards they distribute
like this, it looks like checking the
distribution everything is closed we can
see that inside, that is, there are
no longer simple buyers, it
just distributes food here
in  these bags
are one of the few small shops
that you can still freely go in and
buy something
most of the curtains are already empty,
for example, for onions and sweets, there really is
nothing
chips, too, another empty one
you said that you yourself saw people who were
infected with the corona virus, thank God
no, that is, these terrible shots that I
show there are people
convulsing on the street, it seems to me a little
plausible to read what this
training concerns, I assume that
some other video footage is passed off as the
action of the coronavirus, because again,
this is pneumonia, these are not epileptic attacks, is
it something  that is, people
experience symptoms and all signs
pneumonia and not some kind of nervous
disease or something else, that is, no,
and you have among your
acquaintances there was not a single person at all who, in one
way or another, applied
to a doctor with some symptoms,
but this is an interesting moment because  that as
soon as they announced that there was no
outbreak of an epidemic in the ear, there, among my
environment, there were probably five people, probably 6,
immediately began to experience similar
symptoms, I already experienced
yes yes yes yes, and they started to have a fever, it was
hard to breathe at night, it seemed to the guy that
this  it’s just that in an ordinary flu or
something like that, the diagnosis of
the type of virus is now going on in the ear, and all
these famous shots with checkpoints where they
measure the temperature with long-range thermal imagers
and so on.
or
otherwise open, but this is usually a
grocery store, there is always a
person
here, in his hands, a gun, I measure the
temperature,
that is, nothing special, you come up
this pistol is presented either to the
wrist or to the forehead, they
measured the temperature, everything is fine, you
go through, that is, literally 5-10 seconds, the
procedure takes, and if it’s not normal,
now everyone again has a huge, that
is, a large institution, yes,
there is definitely a police car, and an ambulance,
that is, if  something is not so fast that a
person is imprisoned and taken away for more
serious, apparently some kind of examination,
you say a hospital was organized and
at the stand at the local stadium, it’s just
that there were different tents or an
infinite number, but how it was
that there at the stadium before it was
organized  because at the time of the peak, that
is, 50 thousand people, well, there was simply nowhere
to place them in an ordinary residential courtyard, but the
fence was already surrounded by barbed wire,
just so you can’t get there, the
main idea is to fight this
virus, yes, it’s done so that
in general there are no chances for people to go here  you didn’t
move on this yes yes yes yes yes
to interfere absolutely right, therefore
everyone is trying  to close in my
corner and so that they don’t go, in
general, the cutoff didn’t fly away, I had
such an opportunity, yes, there was an opportunity for
Russia, that is, I organized the evacuation of
citizens, it was, if I’m not mistaken, in the
area there on the five sixths of
February, well, having weighed all the pros and cons, and I decided
to stay because if you fly away from here it’s
not clear when it’s possible to
return back even then, that is, it
turns out there, not twenty years ago, everything was
good enough and but no one could
say, that is, when this situation will end
, that is, here everyone decided at
their own peril and risk here advisers to be
everyone could not have seen this
situation and acted that way, that is, a lot of guys
stayed about the same number of guys flew away
were delivered to tyumen 144 people upon
arrival were all examined
by Rospotrebnadzor specialists and 1 guest
upon arrival with
somatic diseases would he
be transferred to the lecture hospital
why  were brought to you, they had
symptoms, these were people who arrived from the focus of
infection, they were  citizens who
arrived
who were due to very personal
circumstances of life, someone was on a
business trip, someone lived there was on
vacation,
this is from the city of wuhan and there were citizens from the
province of hubei, they were in quarantine and for
14 days
we have such a view of shrinkage with fresh
air  everything is great not 4 price and
you can live even the shower everything is clean everything is
tidy fine with a good view with
fresh air general fruits
feeding now once a day everything is
beautiful pretty check we go in the
morning and in the evening ace changes the temperature
listen check the throat and now he
too  there will be a check on how we
feel, respectively, it also subdues the
temperature, so tomorrow we will go
to take tests, since you and I, how
it is not a big workload for our
medical staff, we filled out questionnaires and now the
treatment of our bones
was overwhelmingly examined by doctors
and two people  were identified as a
suspicious direction of clinical
disease is the island of spartan
zab  they were transferred to a
special hospital, but the
king of the virus infection was not confirmed in them,
according to the results of studies,
no virus RNA particles were found in their biological media, and now a
simple Russian person asks a question
how it turns out that people
who ruled in the very focus of the epidemic for so long
could not
144 people are brought in to be infected here and not a single one is
found to have an infection,
and this is why it must be said that the
province of Hubei
and the city of Wuhan are many millions
inhabited by
such recreations, the probability that
they could meet and become
infected with a new coronavirus is
high, but here it must be said  about the fact that
restrictive measures were taken
to prevent contact with infection,
well, firstly, this is a
restrictive mode of movement around the
settlement, these are
preventive measures for the airborne
droplet infection, wearing the
uterus and observing elementary norms,
this is frequent washing of hands, all this is our
citizens  we observed before being sent on
board to the Russian Federation by
specialists from the People's
Republic
of China, they also took
temperature measurements and they released them
for transportation of persons who did not
have a manifestation of respiratory
diseases there was no increase
in body temperature how did
your doctors act, that is, how soon did you take a
test from them  for the corona virus
how much is ronald the test for
coronavirus went away as he confirmed they
took blood twice blood
smear match case for research
studies were carried out as the city of
tyumen is not this federal budgetary
institution night with a lick there is open
pathology and additionally the second double
dios at the Novosibirsk institute vector our
organization  she is a referral
laboratory for diagnosing a new
coronavirus of the world
health organization and we are also a
reference center for diagnosing a screen of
viral infections in the russian federation and
why why you because the vector has
global experience  t for work with especially
dangerous infections, we have several
laboratories of the highest class of
protection and work with such pathogens
as it was Marburg smallpox and other especially
dangerous viral infections how did
the corona of viral infections start in your vectors
and how did you lose it and how are
you  they said that now you will
do this, but thank God it did
n’t start a corona virus infection, we
are how it got to us samples
how it got there, but look after
January 10, 10, we published the first
nucleotide and the sequence of the new
coronavirus in a week we developed
a diagnostic kit for detecting
this virus and after validating this
kit, the samples began to come to us for
diagnostics, that’s great, and now
let’s explain to a Russian person
what is published by nucleotide and the
sequence is how where
it was published
and what it actually means there is an
international network  there in online
mode with  The division of the complete
sequence of
viruses is a large part of this
influenza virus, which is why, but this network
is now used for online
registration of all specific
sequences of the complete genomes of the
new coronavirus, therefore,
after the Chinese researchers determined the
sequence, they posted it on
this international network and it became
available to the whole world, that is, you
you see conditionally speaking there to carry a certain
formula correctly, I understand we see a
sequence of beeches that
encode a new crane overs in order to
correctly determine the presence of a virus in
the human body daudom aron
virus [ __ ] you need biological material
from China
we don’t we need a follower in order
to develop a diagnostic  method a
molecular diagnostic method based
on the polymerase chain
reaction, only the nucleotide
sequence is sufficient, which was
published on January 10, therefore, based
on this sequence, we
calculated
unique  oligonucleotides are such
fragments that allow in the
polymerase chain reaction to increase the
amount of sample materials and
researchers can already see it on the
screen of their device
in my body, apparently
, somewhere around 40 types of corona
virus are floating, but how does this
new scheme of yours allow the
warring PCR method  allows you to determine the
difference between one corona virus in this
case, a new one, and those corona viruses
that have been living in us already there since when
for a long time and we are not interfered with,
we
take a clinical blood sample from you,
his blood, blood or a swab from the
nasopharynx, and here we activate it
we isolate all the nucleic acids from
there and then we carry out reverse
transcription and a polymerase chain
reaction, so this reaction
allows you to look for a needle in a haystack,
this method allows you to find exactly the
sequence of the new coronavirus
on which it is actually directed, that
is, the error is almost impossible yes,
see this basic  macular
a diagnostic method
that is influenced by several stages,
it is like taking clinical material,
it is transporting it to the laboratory and
directly analyzing it in the laboratory
, at the moment we are
conducting diagnostics in three stages, the first stage is
carried out on the basis of hygiene and epidemiology centers in
eighty-five subjects of
Rospotrebnadzor  and therefore the second
detection of suspicious cases, they then
move on to
diagnostics in 15 support bases of
Rospotrebnadzor and then already comes to
our reference center,
therefore, here the diagnostics goes in 3 stages,
three confirmations and an error, it is excluded.
2 sera, we need a
serological test, we need to know if a
person is sick, not sick, so that
blood drips, a line appears
that says yes, there
are igm class antibodies to this virus, and I
accordingly work with different
industries around the world in order
to find out  who is at what stage
and here I am not on it from xiaomi a group not very
respected by
me they sent me we did a test I
write how much and how it was checked we
had two sera from patients and 100
million negative sera we
delivered 100 million negative  2
patients squeak you assure Novosibirsk
ted in about the same position
maybe they have five sera maybe
now they have 25 but still it only
makes you smile so we
need
to get enough of this
viral material in order to do a normal test yes yes all  in 1
different sera,
because some sera will be and
others will be pregnant from old people 3 from
babies, that is, this is all we
need,
it’s clear, I ask you not to denni a sufficient
amount of biological material, everything
will gain 100 people in six months, it
will be possible to return this is not all that  there is
because it is bad simply because it is still
only a period of development, since the
order circulates in a person  and 40 corona viruses of
different nature, how can we tell
which of these corona viruses has an
intersection with this quite
rightly, that is, it is called a
false positive result, it is interesting
that it is also difficult negative that those of
these 12 thousand
who are actually sick with them, too,
and every hundredth  will not not negative
will not be positive thus
t.s.
currently it has a huge
limitation in order to change this
what we do we first take a
suspect case then a probable
case and then it is tested
so we increase the
prevalence of those group in order
for our test to work
but most importantly still had so refused
and so wrote  and sidisi wrote
stop testing contacts
because contacts are basically healthy
and everything will be false positive in them
happened for saying
quite rightly if
I am not tested for corona
virus infection for example if I myself am healthy
without a temperature without symptoms
I come somewhere  to which laboratory and they
tell me boy, go away from here, do
n’t take our time, that’s right,
yes, that’s right, even more, I’ll
tell you if you take you as a person before
as Anton and test a hundred times
in this test, which in Novosibirsk
once you will  put why one
percent off but after as a result
it’s understandable, therefore, gentlemen and ladies, don’t go
to hospitals, don’t ask to be
tested, otherwise you also
need to have a patient tested, at least with a probable
case, everything scares hello
drasti me anton, your name is anton
not only are you one of the best
pulmonologists in Europe, you are also his main
risk group  now I’ll show you the virus
yourself, literally give recommendations for
people of your generation a little younger, that
is, for those people who now,
as we see, are really prone to
high mortality in China, in Italy and
in the wound,
and in order to understand the problem itself,
you need to understand how the role  corona
viruses as we say biocenosis corona
fought and a very very common
viral infection and a person
meets it in life many many times a
child during the year up to 10 times
suffer a disease that we
call acute colds and
certain
viruses and second place are behind this acute cold  in terms of its
prevalence, it occupies just the
corona virus, which is different  the serotype is not the one
that humanity encountered in 2002
,
usually to charm the film, and then with an
interval of 9 years, the same epidemic came
already in Saudi Arabia, I love the world does not grow
2, I saw the lower 100g to the neighbor
, thanks,
but in this situation that
happened today, the same after nine years
pay attention to the interval of
9 years according to the latest classifications, it
is called sars tyrakov tyr
-2 the disease itself has at least
four such
outlined stages the first stage of this
virus and harmless colds there is
nothing special 7 days 9
approximately in this interval, but
starting from 9 to 14 days  the situation
changes qualitatively because it is during
this period that the virus is formed for
bacterial understanding, hitting the
epithelial cells, in this
anatomical space of the respiratory
tract colonization occurs colonization occurs for the
microorganism, first of
all, those that inhabit the
foil of the same parallel parallel
bacteria are never important, and this is how the mechanisms are arranged  protection measures
that it is the
lower respiratory tract, they
don’t have me, they settled when the virus
invaded and it violated this barrier, then
where there was a sterile environment in the lungs,
it becomes an environment
where microorganisms begin to colonize,
multiply if this
situation is
some
of the disease progresses,
then they already begin  more serious such
complications, we call it
respiratory distress syndrome, shock, a
person can’t solve it on his own,
and this pulmonary edema, if we say
cardiogenic edema to the hatch,
we can help with certain
medications, then this pulmonary
edema can be treated only with the help
of a
mechanical ventilation machine e-  mail and if a
person endures this phase, then
immunosuppression is caused by a lesion of
acquired
and innate immunity, it becomes
fatal and the patient joins
such aggressive pathogens as
Pseudomonas aeruginosa fungi and those
deaths that occurred in 50 percent of
those who are long-term  drank on the
art of a-level lung ventilation and
everything is legal mushrooms
mushrooms appear when deep
immunosuppression,
but here you are, how is your site, I get to
you, we definitely understand that
an elderly person comes to you, he can accurately
diagnose corr probably and he is
not yet on the ninth  days, yes, that is, it is
not yet necessary, probably in the classroom, how
will you treat him, you will find him, I do
not treat such patients yet, because there is
no, therefore, because there are no these
drugs
drugs that should be used in this
phase
in situations that are the most formidable  that
it determines the fate of a person with a cold,
another state is one thing, and another thing
when a
sad bacterial understanding is a
fundamentally different thing, and here it is
very important to emphasize that it is problematic to
help such a patient
with
antibiotics alone.  prescribe immunomo  duplicating
this question for scientific research, so
we understand that immunity will suffer sharply,
we understand a high visa for a
person who has an infection that
begins to colonize his respiratory
tract,
so unfortunately we
don’t have such a clear line, but what
can really help such patients in
such a situation is  immunoglobulin
replacement therapy
can be why I am so sick that they
break out sepsis at least I did not
enter the phase with coronary artery disease and prescribe immunoglobulins in the bustle
unfortunately that in the world it
all depends on where you got the
source of the virus in the textbook we will write
that the corona virus of the nineteenth year  gave
such and such a lethality when the chip
runs out, look in Korea for
lethality, that is, from the number of cases that have
died
today,
ignoring how many more will die
tomorrow, the day after tomorrow, tomorrow, the day after tomorrow,
we will figure it out 0 5 and a hundred in Italy from
two to three there by day  to
hesitate, that is, they are what kind of virus to the
floor  Chile, the very first
one, brought one of the early
viruses, the same one, no mutation, it
just has variations, it is still
adapting to the Italians now, and the
Koreans have already received the virus from somewhere
in the province, which are repeated and it
flows much easier, that is, in theory, for
now  there is no vaccine, maybe you need
to go to karelia now it’s easy to get over all of us
in quarantine right now the city is not completely
closed, that is, the roads are open the
only thing is they check the road
before leaving another city checks the
temperature
time, that is, it is not around the clock from
other cities provides medical
staff provide it to the city
you come here a lot and doctors
and nurses as authorities what the authorities say
what the authorities recommend doing to residents
now comes every hour approximately
come with a bowl to the phone and come
to  observed their hygiene observed
because  the herd always walks past them
and don’t touch Tom’s face,
try the executioners to civilize it more often,
and then some gloves are
already walking what means of protection the
authorities recommend
now.  do I need to, and of course,
public places not to wear a mask are
now distributed free of charge to each
family about four
to four things a week, then they
are sold in a pharmacy in pharmacies now
large production concerns have been closed
from all production, only 10
percent can leave these  masks
abroad outside of Korea, the
remaining 8 percent should be
sold almost and at cost price now,
this one is sold at the post office and in some
large these such stores the queues
are very long for masks
for masks very long per day in
each to each district there is a post office  to
this mail for each person it turns out
by March 5 you have the right only to  drink
5 masks and only for 250 people at the
moment, as things are with
food and, by the
way, such household necessities if there are
queues in stores, is it possible to safely
buy food and so on, as the
news on the Internet shows you now,
so I don’t know the shelves there
empty that people are right
they have such a hype there is no such thing or the
herd you come in fact are
bought for a lot why just
next you go out less as
if in public places only because of
this they
extended the holidays for three weeks until the 23rd of transport
now in  basically a city within a city
all vehicles basically everything by
car if they themselves are driving, that is,
public transport, they try not to
use anyone, therefore,
long-distance transport has
become much less waffle than it was
before, listen, but among your
acquaintances,
personal or acquaintances, acquaintances among people
whom  you work
there are people who
got the corona virus infection in
such people you know  I don’t have any
acquaintances either, but in our area there is
one
artistic school, they went to this art school, which means that
my friends, how to say, the children went
and there they found this coronavirus in the teacher,
but yes, she just
had a bad cough, she had a high temperature,
but she is now  until now she is in the
hospital still lies as far as I
know now somewhere
all over korea 124 in place there are large all
hospitals for coronavirus to go through
this go through italy
well or not only go through treatment well and get
checked for corrado  I take it and expand even more
and small hospitals began
to open and there are hotlines to
which you call call call so that
they ask you what symptoms
are you more than 4 within 14 days have you been
in China everything that asks you if
you have just let's say  temperature
then at first they burn all the same 12 days
at home stay this later if you have a
duration to come already in some kind of
obligatory and obligatory  the hospital
where exactly they prescribe and I’ll go and
ask about it like that, I want to take the
test, it won’t work, too, yes-ah-ah, it’s just that
you will wait much longer for them, then of
those who have symptoms if they take
a test for this in 6 hours and
I’ll tell you about it within two days, either they’ll
call you or with a wash, then if you
come in your own way, you’ll say that
one coronavirus you want to give up,
you’re a little bit like other people get sick
first, then the mat virus is an
unstable population, it’s not like that
now we have a virus in italy italy and
here we have a virus in korea this is with the
flu since the eighteenth year we came to this
it finally separates inside
finally it multiplies the Hong Kong
Asian virus they take and this one that
just came out he still doesn’t
understand anything he still still  a bunch of shama lash
in this way is very difficult to model
i don't believe in all these models they are all very
rude a very important point that i
always say who decides
on bo  fight against the virus, well, who is the
government,
yes, the government,
how old is the government, but how much do they assess
this threat is comparable in terms of
students or not comparable, and this is
absolutely right because if you
now give this virus a huge
spread, then no system can
cope, not only medical
economic no  hand attacks, I’m
just explaining to you why
governments around the world are so focused on this
virus, do you think that people people
who don’t understand anything get into the
government it doesn’t happen
they are the first to understand the greatest threat
is to which segment of the population
this virus is practically the most dangerous
for the chopping class in everything
how relieved would
most of the people on the planet be if this
happens yes you think the planet
won't have a carnage
after this happens you guys never
think in terms of numbers in my
business you think in terms you have
someone elderly who  do you love you es  t .
something the elderly cared for you, think with what
thoughts and then you will immediately understand the
situation of this life, it is necessary to explain
all the details of the
truth and in no case should you
deceive, and the main thing is that it is the
responsibility of everyone
if you have elderly neighbors whom
you treat well with your own
parents  think about it further, look,
and in America a sheet of what you need
to buy in 15 days is common, for
example, everything is ready for me
to get 25 liters of water left,
so let's tell because you
canned juices for the funeral, these are the
canned fruits, because there is such a
sheet on really  it is impossible to develop such a
list in Russia
so that people are ready for the fact that if
they appear at the training camp, there is nowhere to go
and infect no one when there will be no need for
these Chinese stadiums, because these are two
systems, you can understand that you can drive everyone to
Chinese stadiums and the Chinese are
wonderful, wonderful  controlled
someone inside the opera stadiums was infected, but
they all already  closed 2 hospitals but about the
united states, why let everyone
at home sit to seal the windows so that it’s not
there and not the barrel, and yes, if it’s not heavy, what
difference does it make the last thing to do, as
we said self-isolation if
you are sick, correct your wife’s ticks and
try to say so  not to infect anyone,
this is the very first thing if you are a
young person you will get sick
easily and in
a week everything will go away if you are
an elderly person be sure to
notify your doctor call the
clinic say that you have such and
such a situation that your nephew
came  whether from korea from italy, here he
sneezes, that is, this is the most important thing here,
this work with self-control is
prepared by itself so that you don’t have to
sit in the queues of the clinic and
hook on some other
world
mask to mask, but just remember that
if you go to  to the patient that this mask
only works for 20 minutes you sit next
to the patient
it protects you only for 20 minutes if you
wear a mask  sick it is very good you
will not infect others accordingly
watch the temperature because it
appears first and know that a barking
flaming dry cough is a very
unpleasant prognostic
syndrome in relation to this disease